is anubhav and today i'll be presenting
an efficient semi-streaming ptas for the
tournament feedback arcside problem done
in few passes
so let's just start with defining what
the problem is
we first define the cost of a
permutation with respect to a specific
vertex at v and a weight matrix w for
each ordered pair
the weight matrix w represents the
adjacency matrix of the directed graph
where w u v equals 1 if and only if
there exists a directed edge from u to v
the goal of the feedback oxide problem
is to find the permutation that
minimizes this total cost that's
displayed in the slide here
and for tournament graphs
there is only one directed edge between
every given pair of vertices
we essentially want to just find a
permutation that minimizes the number of
edges
going backwards
for that particular ordering and we want
to find the ordering which minimizes the
number of these total back edges
in the streaming setting each edge will
be listed exactly once in a given pass
uh and this problem is np hard even for
tournament graphs as shown by alone
but we have a ptas for tournament graphs
in the non-systematic streaming setting
in the non-streaming setting
as it was first presented by
warren and shooti
so let's discuss the motivations and
applications
of this particular problem
firstly the treatment feedback archer
problem can be rephrased as the ranking
by pair wise comparison problem or the
rpc problem
where we want to obtain an ordering of
items from least preferred to most
preferred when we are given pairwise
preferences between all pairs of items
and we want to minimize the number of
disagreements
this is like identical to the
feedback side problem for two number
graphs
and this problem is very useful for kim
any young aggregation problem which is
then further useful for search engine
results and machine translation
one can also
reduce the loop cut side problem to a
black or feedback vertex had problem to
decrease the computational cost of bayes
and inference using the feedback arcset
problem
so that is another application of this
problem
and
similar directory graph problems such as
sd connectivity and strongly connected
components which we also study uh in
this paper can also serve as subroutines
for applications such as model checking
and formula verification or data flow
analysis for compiler optimization
so let's discuss some previous work done
on the tournament feedback arcsight
problem
as mentioned earlier the minimum
feedback auxiliary problem is known to
be np-hard even for tournament graphs so
previous results include k vic sword and
its extension given by chakraborty at
all who give a multi-pass
streaming algorithm that achieves an
approximation factor of three
ilon also
gave a one plus epsilon approximation
algorithm called sample and rank that
reduces query complexity compared to the
ptas which in some ways is similar to
the streaming setting where input access
is limited
another important thing to note is that
chakrabarty at all also
get a one pass semi streaming algorithm
using a brute force sketching methods
which takes exponential time so the key
challenge here is to obtain better
bounds for polynomial time algorithms as
that is the key
missing part in the current
body of work
so
we first present our
key result of the paper which is
uh the first piece p test that gives a
one plus epsilon approximation with
constant probability to the minimum
feedback oxide problem on tournament
graphs
uh it requires at most uh o star and
space if done in login passes uh here
like the o star notation basically just
hides log n
poly log n and poly
one over epsilon factors for clarity
uh and furthermore this algorithm can be
modified to work in p passes as long as
we
give some leeway for space and uh
uh
say that it like and allow for o star of
n to the one plus one over p space
uh so we first uh want to discuss what
single vertex moves are because these
are the key local optimization method
that are used in the original p task by
warren and shooti for the tuned feedback
arc set problem and also in the query
efficient algorithm given by alon
the idea is to just pick a vertex in the
current permutation and move it to
another index in such a way that the
total cost of the new permutation is
lower
so in this example where we are omitting
all the forward edges for clarity you
can only like see the packages in this
particular example on the slide
uh the cost and the original permutation
is 12
because that is just how many packages
there are but after moving the vertex a
to index three uh
the total cost is now 11 so this is a
cost improving single vertex move since
the total cost went down from 12 to 11.
um so now we'll discuss like some of the
key insights that go into
obtaining this new algorithm
uh since the algorithm can only use n
polylogin over epsilon space we cannot
directly calculate the cost improvement
that we can obtain from single vertex
moves
and we therefore need to do that by
using sampling
we also want to keep enough copies of
these samples so that the samples stay
fresh with respect to the permutation
after making a single vertex move
because we want these samples to be
independent
of the permutation that we obtain after
making a single vertex move so in a way
we wouldn't require a new sample because
the sample that we have originally
already used is no longer going to be
independent of the new permutation
um
another very important insight is that
in order to get a one plus epsilon
approximation
we only need to execute strong single
vertex moves and strong single vertex
moves are
ones in which are which are long
and have significant cost improvement uh
we'll get into what a long and
significant cause from significant hair
mean later on
and
finally in order to get a poly login
over epsilon passes
we make several single vertex moves in
parallel so that the permutation we're
working with changes less often this is
made possible due to the fact that
two single vertex moves can only affect
each other's cost by of one
so
the realized cost improvement of
multiple single vertex moves made at
once
is
similar to the cost improvement if the
moves were done individually
uh
okay so let's go over
the high level description of the
algorithm uh the first step is to just
obtain a five approximation
of the minimum feedback arc set a result
by coppersmith at all shows that simply
sorting by in degree of
vertices achieves this and
sorting by in degree can obviously be
done in just n log n uh space and in one
pass so
that is straightforward
um now if the size of the sub problem is
smaller than log n over log log n
then we can just brute force through all
the possible permutations in one pass by
storing all the edges in that sub
problem that is also straightforward
otherwise
we use a small sample of edges which
gives us an additive o of epsilon
squared n squared approximation of the
feedback arc set with high probability
and if the cost is too high
uh
then we run the quadratic additive
approximation algorithm for the minimum
feedback auxiliary problem by freeze at
all which we show can be implement
implemented in a streaming setting
um
if we haven't hit any of these base
cases we perform single vertex moves on
the sub problem until the terminating
condition for approx local improve is
hit which is a method that we use and
we'll like get into the details of
and then we'll just recurse on the two
smaller sub problems in a randomized
quick sort fashion by picking a pivot
and just going down the two sub problems
so now let's uh discuss the key uh
optimization method used by algorithm
which is approx local improve
uh
this is the like the real meat of the
algorithm because this performs all the
actual single vertex moves
we start by creating these sample sets
evi for each vertex v which help us
approximate the cost of
a cost improvement of single vertex
moves on vertex v
uh
and
now
we want to be able to do all the strong
single uh vertex moves that are
available on this particular sub problem
and so as long as there exists a strong
single vertex moves we keep executing
these single vertex moves which is
similar to what alons algorithm also
does
making these single vertex moves can
change the permutation enough that the
new strong single vertex moves arise
which is why we need multiple sample
sets for each vertex and need to repeat
this process again and again
however the number of times that the
process repeats is only
poly log n or epsilon so the number of
passes needed is also poly log n over
epsilon
uh so before we get into the proof idea
and structure we need to better specify
what contributes to the cost of the
feedback arc set on a permutation return
by the algorithm
the total cost can be partitioned
into
uh sets beta x and alpha x as uh
displayed on this slide
where x is just some arbitrary node in
the recursion tree and comprises of like
certain subset of the vertices
alpha x is the cost incurred at a leaf
node x and beta x is the cost incurred
at an internal node x so the idea is
that we have an internal node that is
split into two smaller sub problems l
and r
or i guess v l and v r
uh then all the vertices and v r are
always going to be ahead of all the
vertices in vl in any permutation that
is returned by the algorithm so this is
a commitment
that the algorithm is going to make
because
once uh
the part
once the partition is made in the
recursive algorithm then
the
right side of the recursion
is always going to have vertices that
are ahead of like all the vertices in
the left side of the permutation
uh
because those
two sub problems are never going to
interact with each other later on
uh
therefore beta x here
quantifies that permanent cost that the
final permutation is going to have no
matter what
um
and now one important thing to note here
is that the recursive structure of our
algorithm is the same as the one in
alan's algorithm
only the base case and the local
optimization method approx local improve
are different therefore as long as we
make any single vertex moves that allows
algorithm would also make then we should
be able to use the above lemma about the
cost at the internal nodes of the
regression tree as proved by alon
here uh i
uh like
like mathcal i represents the set of
internal nodes of the recursion tree and
l is the set of leaves
uh the above lemma essentially states
that the cost induced at their internal
nodes plus the minimum possible cost at
the leaves is at most one plus epsilon
times the optimal cost
and the expectation here is taken over
the choice of the pivots in the
recursion
this lemma is very useful since we're
getting close to an optimal solution on
the leaves using the additive
approximation by freeze at all anyway
so
all we really need to show now is that
we make all the strong single vertex
moves possible in
a prox local improve and we do that in
like
in a
few passes and
only polylogan over epsilon space
so yeah this is this is the key lemma i
was speaking about
so finally in order to show that we make
all
strong single vertex moves in the approx
local improve method in one pass
with the o star of n space we first know
that the realized cost improvement of
every strong single vertex move is
linear in n
because they're long
and have significant cost improvement by
definition um
so
a long single vertex move uh is just one
where
the length of the single vertex moves
that is like the number of spaces that
the vertex that we are moving spans is
linear in
the size of the sub problem
and a significant cost improvement also
just means that the
imp cost improvement incurred by
the particular single vertex move is
linear in the length of the move itself
so
that means a strong single vertex move
is going to have a cost improvement
that's linear
in the size of the sub problem
the number of single vertex moves that
the algorithm is required to make
in order to create a new strong single
vertex move is also linear in n
so the amount of caution movement that
the algorithm is required to make in
order to create a new strong single
vertex move is quadratic n
since the maximum cost of a feedback arc
set can only be on the order of n
squared
this means that the number of times new
strong single vertex moves are created
is o star of one
um so the algorithm requires a new
sample set every time new strong single
vertex moves are potentially created
because
the
samples that we used to make and find
the first set of strong single vertex
moves are not stale
they're not independent of the new
permutation and therefore cannot be used
to approximate the cost of new single
vertex moves
um
but as we showed the number of such sets
that we need per vertex is all star one
which means that the number of sets that
we need in total is o star of n as
desired
uh
finally since every call to a prox local
improve uh requires one pass the entire
algorithm only requires of log n passes
with high probability
one for each layer of the recursion tree
which
concludes our discussion of the proof of
correctness
one uh another key thing to note is that
this algorithm can be modified
to
uh
be done in p passes with o star of n to
the one plus one over p space which is
similar to the trade-off achieved by
chakrabarthy at all for their three
approximation algorithm
the idea is to partition the layers of
the recursion tree in such a way
that every partition is executed in one
pass
since we need to execute multiple layers
of the recursion tree in one pass
we need to store much larger sample sets
which are used for approximating cost of
single vertex moves
and it turns out that if we partition
the layers in such a way as described in
the slide here where the size of the sub
where we partition them based on the
size of the sub problem that we're
seeing
then the algorithm only requires
o star of n to the one over
b samples per vertex which gives us our
desired space constraints
that parks are problem
we also explore the field of director
graph problems in the semi streaming
setting and the streaming setting and
present a few smaller results
these results include a deterministic
algorithm for detecting
the strongly critical components of a
tournament graph
this is done by first computing a
hamiltonian path in a tournament graph
in a streaming setting using kvxsort
uh but we also present a deterministic
algorithm for computing the hamiltonian
path in the streaming setting thereby
achieving the deterministic algorithm
for detecting strongly connected
components
we also demonstrate single pass space
lower bounds through communication
complexity reductions for the problems
of determining if a graph is strongly
connected acyclic and a sol connectivity
uh finally we also obtain multipass
lower bounds for strongly kinetic
components by reducing it to decision
versions of the set chasing problem by
gorswami and monach
thank you so much for listening
have a good have a great day